to South Africa now where the number of
rhinos being poached dropped last year
for the first time since 2007 is being
put down to increased policing and
combat operations one private anti
poaching unit which has had considerable
success as the black mambas it's a group
made up entirely of women who live in
communities or during the kruger
national park i love nature since when I
was high school I fell in love with a
nature
there I no means a lot in my life I see
Rhino as an animal that deserved to live
every day when I woke up going to patrol
defense I work with that happiness that
people can see us they won't get inside
our reserve they will know that inside
out their reserve there is people that
are working every day
it's a nice thing working inside the
reserve because you will develop that
life of the animals it was 2012 when I
first see the Rhinos at bush school so
that time I felt that I have to fight
for the Rhinos it was my first time
seeing a deadline it was painful dip
down to my heart it's had to forget and
it's hard to look at that deadline it is
painful scary but it was the first time
in 2015 inside our safe and it was the
last time one rest until we catch that
poachers cuz we will fight for the
Rhinos will fight for world in months
to be a black mamba it changed my life a
lot
because now i know who i am now I can
fight for everything that I have because
I have that live inside my heart of
their highness so I am proud to be a
black young woman doing anti-poaching
this is our nature even our children
want to see it they want to see their
real rhinos not the pictures i have
hoped that we can win this battle
well Craig Spencer is the man who
founded the black mambas he joins us
live from hood spray near the kruger
national park good morning craig morning
wanna Craig why did you form the black
members well they're in 2013 when the
the rhino poaching sort of hit our part
of the reserve which is open to the the
Kruger National Park now we needed some
different tools in our toolbox unis on
different to tangle you know throwing
the same old rusty tools at the same old
job you know machine guns and
militarizing our game Ranger Corps
hadn't worked in the past it just sort
of slowed it down a little bit so we
needed a different intervention as
you're not mixing I think it's very
interesting that they're not armed
whereas poachers traditionally are
heavily armed so how has that approached
approach helped we we try to model our
anti poaching unit on the British
policing model yes sir the first level
of defense is the the bobbies on the
beat so to speak and that's always been
what's lacking in our opinion we needed
that early detection the eyes and ears
the visual policing and somebody with a
nurturing attitude you know somebody who
actually cared more about the Rhinos and
then trying to catch poachers so you
know we'd rather prevent the Rhinos from
dropping now to the purchase bullets
then wait for the poacher to shoot the
runner so that we've got a strong case
in court you know as a conservationist
our job is that should protect them not
to catch poachers so yo the black
numbers added a different dimension
something that we never had before it
meant that we could also deploy our
armed God's more appropriately to
protect the assets if the poachers did
slip through the net so when you went
into these communities and approached
these women what was their response
initiative yeah it's quite sad we had
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
applications you know it's obvious that
there's a huge unemployment problem in
the communities adjacent to the park you
put up an advertisement for whatever it
is and thousands of people will apply
for the job not quite knowing what they
were getting themselves in for and then
of course you're in the training
procedure in a lot of the important for
us and so on but you know the ones that
were selected at the end the 26 did was
selected for the training not a single
one of them dropped off the training and
I think it gave him a sense of pride the
things are belonging purpose and Craig
what sort of a response had the black
members had what sort of a success level
have they had and can you quantify it
yeah I think you know for us it was hot
an eye-opener to see exactly just how
much antisocial behavior we had both
inside the park and what we call the
buffer zone around the park in the
tribal lands you know the bush meat
industry the sneering illegal camps the
people coming and going through the
porous boundary fences and whenever
there was quite a shock to us we didn't
actually have a handle on that and that
was the first task of the black members
they use their own initiative and the
way that they pushed all of that anti
social will be called antisocial
behavior outside of the park well beyond
the boundaries of the park burnt down
the protest camps discovered the areas
where they were coming in and art you
know what the modus operandi is were
little things like they they need to
have cell phone reception to be able to
contact a pickup vehicle when they get
back outside the park that's where the
areas we you know the hot spots where
you need to concentrate your efforts the
sneering issue you know we were losing
as many animals to purchase snares than
we were to the poachers bullets in fact
we probably lost more high-value
endangered species is nearing
non-selective approaching methods and
effectively had people living inside the
reserving of the bush camps and things
that you couldn't detect with a
helicopter or anything like that those
are the density of the vegetation and
the purchase routed all of this art they
also became quite a sort of where of the
behavior of the animals as well so they
knew which animals are using which water
holes you know when they were most
vulnerable on the landscape and
therefore way to focus their attention
so yeah if you answer your question in
the beginning before we deployed the
black numbers in the first few months
when the perches discovered our rhino
population we lost 19 animals they
dropped like dominoes we couldn't keep
up with the autopsies and the crime
reports a very shortly thereafter we
gave us a
until that was in April and then we gave
ourselves until March varina April
mid-september gave ourselves until
September to deploy and after deployment
we relaxed and after 13 months we hadn't
lost a single rider since then in a
three and a half years we've only lost
seven where is our neighbors have taken
quite a hit so we've actually just
displaced the problem elsewhere that at
least I can say in our neck of the woods
no more animals have been lost his
snares and no more animals have been
lost to pictures now Craig you're a
private citizen why is the government
not dealing with this why do you have to
why do you have to do it yeah it's quite
a challenge you know to have a a three
leveled approach to anti-poaching i
think is a luxury item that we can
afford in the private sector we get a
small subsidy from the south african
national parks board who are our
neighbors to the east and to the south
that the rest of the money we have to
raise it ourselves through fundraising
events and and so on a lot of donor
funding a lot of intervention from the
public both overseas and locally and I
just don't think the government has the
mechanism for what they would call a
luxury item you know where as we believe
it's an essential Oliver and also if I
have enough power for so we must
remember that the black Mama's fifty
percent of their job is on the reserve
the other fifty percent is off the
reserve back in their communities
working with the people working in the
school rooms they look after the sick
and the poor and the needy and the
children and whatever you and it's
essential that we have their component
as well we need to build up a sort of
almost like a french resistance in the
communities against the poachers to
break this Robin Hood attitude that the
poachers our hero is in the path is that
a sort of Sherwood Forest okay Craig
Spencer talking to us from head spirit
the founder of the black mambas thank
you very much